this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to honor.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like
pressing code joey and get 10 off
delivered right to your house what's
happening you bad [__] it's
monday the 9th of may the joint is
brought to you by sheath underwear
listen if you listen to the joint you
probably got a [__] huge dick and
you're probably sick of reaching down to
get it unstuck from your balls thank god
there's sheath underwear listen
it keeps your balls off your legs the
idea for sheath came across its founder
us army soldier robert patton during his
second tour in iraq if it worked for him
it'll work for you
these [__] underwear are tremendous
comfortable
support the show and support this old
awesome veteran-owned company go to
sheetsunderwear.com and use promo code
joey i'm going to get you 20 off your
first order just go to
sheetsunderwear.com
and take a look at the designs they have
a little pocket under the ball sack just
in case you're a part-time smuggler i'm
telling you they're tremendous every
order comes with a sheet underwear 100
money back guarantee that sheet
underwear dot com use promo code joey
j-o-e-y
get sheet underwear and let them support
your [__] tremendous nuts that sheet
underwear dot com use promo code joey
and get 20 off your first order this is
tremendous i'm talking about bespoke
post
shake up your daily routine with bespoke
post and their new box of awesome
collections i got one sent to me i said
let me tell you what was in there okay
i got four whiskey glasses
i got a bottle to put the whiskey in
there's a name for it but i don't know
what it is i'm not in intelligent or
educated like that
they sent me a one-hitter that's
tremendous with a little joint holder
and a little pouch [__] beautiful but
they sent me a knife i'm not talking
about little [__] you know camping
knife with a toothpick in it i'm talking
about this is a rambo knife jack
bespoke post partners with small
businesses to bring you the most unique
goods every month they got collections
for every part of your life like their
scorch box
with hot sauces from all over the
country to get started take the quiz at
box of awesome dot com and they'll help
pick the right box for you
each box is valued at seventy dollars
but you only pay a fraction of that plus
90 of everything in each box is from a
small up-and-coming brand
it's free to sign up and you could skip
a month or cancel any time get 20 off
your first monthly box
when you sign up at boxingawesome.com
and enter code joey at checkout that's
box of awesome dot com
code joey for 20 off your first box
box of awesome.com
code joey let's get this party started
it's monday morning we got some [__] to
talk about jimmy schubert is in studio
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
so
what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday may the 9th my mother's
birthday in hell well that's where i
think she's at anyway it's a fun-filled
[__] week i hope you guys had a great
time on cinco de mayo you jumped up and
down you crashed the car you got a dui
that's what most dui's happen on cinco
the [__] mayo people lose their
goddamn minds but it's gonna be a great
week
it's shitty weather today but i got my
man
jimmy two shoes shubert in studio
philadelphia's finest what's going on
what's up brother nothing you know
[__] here in jersey it's a rainy
[__] day
i came by yeah i came by and a slice of
pizza hung out i missed you you know was
just because i got out of l.a la2 bro
doug we got on the [__] first train
out
rogan
we won the first train jack [__] you
everybody everybody scatters i went
right up in delray florida you're up in
thomas river new jersey up here i mean
it's freaking it's uh yeah it's you know
it's [__] steve simone's in florida
lee's in boston yeah half of [__]
comedies in austin yeah you know and i
gotta tell you man i saw roseanne on
stage in austin the other day she went
down there yeah and was [__] around
with joe and ron white yeah yeah yeah
and i got to be honest i think it's
going to be
i want you know i want to do some comedy
some sets
and i think i'm going to go down there
for a couple days oh you should just do
a couple sets with those guys
it seems like they're having a good
comedy time well yeah you know i was
just down there i did the rumble room
but i was down there i did a episode of
kill tony i mean these guys that vulcan
gas company uh right across the streets
the cake and the cream and the cake and
making the cake creek in the cave but
they're like like like right within a
two block area and then you know joe was
looking at a building down there i know
so it's gonna be i mean that whole area
is gonna be what's going on with the
club that was there all those years
you know what's interesting uh margie
yeah the cap city council
but that but that club they closed and
then it reopened i and i think at some
point somebody thought looked at that
building i thought maybe they buying it
but they put like a big price tag on it
was like no not really we can do
anything you want you know i mean they
should have done that but
i i remember it was a pretty decent room
had a real nice big show room and on the
outside but i bought it was another
little stage there it was a nice club
but i think they they uh
went out of business
i heard that
margie her
her mate of many years passed away right
before the pandemic yeah so she wasn't
doing good with the pandemic hit and
then
she was looking to sell the club but
they put a heavy price tag on it that
could have been a very easy move to
rogan yeah but they put a big price they
read they sold 100 million and they
wanted and that that mall is is you know
it's
it looks like a mall in north hollywood
yeah you know
karate school
you know in that character no it's
missing you can see a good a good
[__] wind blowing that that club is
gone but yeah you know i went down there
and i was very impressed with i didn't
go out that night i had to come right
back i think i'm going to go down there
in may and then one time in june i went
down there and so we're at the uh
creek in the cave
and then the back is just wide open on
it and it's tony hitchcliff is brian
it's adam eagan from
everybody like the manager was like um
uh mitchell
they were all like it was i felt like
behind at the comedy store but they were
all the la people all the comedy store
people were there it was a blast man i
had a great time with those you know and
and for me it was listen
i'm too [__] long in the tooth to go
down there and think i'm gonna plant
[__] whatever you know
but it's nice to just i like seeing
those kids doing that yeah i like i
really like seeing those kids
[__] grinding it out it does
something to me just because i don't
want to do it at that pace anymore
doesn't mean i don't encourage people to
[__] do it so it's kind of nice i
like what they're doing down there yeah
it's a real scene man it's hollywood
without the [__] hollywood so it's
got to be beautiful
any time there's stand up
and there's no hollywood involved
it's as pure
and as down and dirty as it could be
yeah man so
you know when you see guys like jimmy
myself
we went through that scene i mean jimmy
was there with kennison jimmy was there
when it was really mattered yeah
so it was crazy yeah when it really
[__] mattered jimmy was there so
think about it i mean
we
were a little older now you know i mean
if i didn't have mercy and the [__]
wife
i would go on the road with the end with
the gold for somebody to find me dead
that's it
what are you gonna do if you don't have
a wife and a kid you're gonna go on the
road
get your dicks up or jeez
light your nutsack on fire you know
you're gonna do all these things because
there's no
there's no anchor you know when i had
when i didn't have an anchor the road
was [__]
a magical place it was the wizard of oz
i didn't know where i was going every
weekend i was going to houston but i
ended up in a [__] white supremacist
camp snorting coke in beaumont texas
saying i hate jews you know that's just
the way it is that's the adventure that
comedy gives you you know that's the
adventure if you're in for that
adventure
once you're married and you have a child
you know listen man the last 10 years i
did comedy and i got to be honest all i
thought about was that get them giving
me that check on saturday night yeah
it's all i gave it once you gave me that
check the pictures disappeared
you know so what's going on in america i
don't know it's over you gave me the
check it's over yeah there's no more
pictures the only thing i have on my
mind
is going home i wish i had the money to
[__] take a jet home right now
the hardest thing of the road is after
you get that check waiting for that
[__] plane waiting for that car to
call you at 5 55. going we're here and
you're like [__]
hold on i gotta smoke a half a joint
then you get in there that's all i loved
about it was getting paid that's why i'm
doing
what i did
thank god i [__] came to that
conclusion that was the best part of my
weekend
the best part of my comedy weekend was
getting to a town eating that first
dinner
that first good restaurant dinner
or whatever that city has to offer that
to me is [__] king knowing you have a
show at eight o'clock
it's sold out and knowing you're gonna
go back to your room smoke a [__]
pound of weed and watch [__] hbo max
till four in the morning because you
ain't got radio friday all you gotta do
is get up go to breakfast go to the
[__] gym that's it you know that's
that's life i love that [__]
but
that hotel stay now
saturday i'm ready to commit suicide i'm
ready to pull the chris cornell
i'm ready to pull a belt around my
[__] neck on saturday because that's
all that's why i have jimmy here because
i don't want him to sit in a hotel room
on a [__] saturday i didn't forget
that [__] yeah you know what's
interesting is you're right you just
once it gets to a point like i've been
everywhere in america probably
everywhere probably 15 times like just
touring around all over and then
like uh
like they're doing uh
getting to do those military tours where
you would go to like like or you go to
asia and i go yeah i would go when i was
just doing it because it was different
than like it like i would get to go to
asia but first off i know people spend
don't work their whole lives and save
money to go to see like you know beijing
and the great wall of china and
tiananmen square and all and i'm like
over there i've literally said you're
flying to beijing for a one-nighter i
had two days off so i went and saw
tiananmen square and then we fly up to i
went up to shanghai but i'm going at
least it was something different than
just like doing the the road in america
you know you just have to break up the
monotony of it like i would do those
military tours or something like me
steve byrne
uh pedro hernandez drew carey calls me
and goes
hey uh
jimmy drew hey drew he goes uh he was
thinking about maybe bringing if you
wanted to join us we're going to
afghanistan to do shows and i go yeah i
was thinking about going there anyway
aaron's loving this time of year in
august he starts laughing and then we we
got you you're flying into these
military like they got to fit you for a
kevlar vest and a helmet
and you're on this like alpha clash
chinook
and you've got a patchy escort and
you're firing cattle measures off the
back and i'm sitting there like like you
know i'm not nervous you know and you
carries get the helmet down like like
he's fixing people like
what the [__] is wrong with you how many
guys kind of okay you got two shows on
television
but he used to be a marine so these were
the kind of things that he would do like
it was like i do this because
i feel bad for these guys but i mean
that's like adventure travel you know i
mean you talk about the just the basic
stuff because you're going i mean it's
24 hours of straight flying to get the
doha guitar and from there you're on a
c130 and then you're on these things
doing these forward operating bases and
we're getting off the chopper
and you get to
the guy goes what are you doing here
i go we're the comedians he goes yeah
but what are you doing here like
we must
be goes come on but i mean it was kind
of you know that was
it get to the point it was better than
stay in the hotel room and you know
somewhere in you know podunk iowa you're
right it's so weird the road the journey
of the road you know
it's it's [__] like you go as a
feature act
and you go and then they like you at the
club and they bring you back like in six
weeks six months then you come back to
six months and
now they know who you are you know who
they are they're very nice to you very
nice to them and then you meet a girl on
friday night you do a couple lines with
a sadly you swap some spit maybe you
suck at titties and you promise your
call i'm not gonna sleep with you
because i don't want to be one of your
groupies on the road okay whatever i
don't know groupies on the road i just
date chicks that do blow and have dirty
feet that's all i look for so
so then you come back to that thing and
now you do coconut and she actually
sleeps with you
and you have like a nice weekend then
she tells you she doesn't want to have a
commitment and you you don't give a [__]
you just go to the next town and hope
there's a freak there too and then you
come back again a year later
and this time she comes to the show and
hooks up with you but she tells you i
got a boyfriend
we can't do that no more you're like god
damn it
but he wants to meet you you know and
all this [__] now you gotta meet her and
the [__] boyfriend and then the next
time she calls she's like we gonna meet
not really if you're not licking i'm not
buying you know what i'm saying so take
your [__] romance somewhere else it's
it's so weird you see these people grow
up you go to these like i didn't have
the opportunities that jimmy had going
abroad because i'm a [__] criminal i
got no [__] passport so i got stuck
going over and over to the same clubs
and i gotta tell you something honest
i really enjoyed myself i gotta say
in all the american cities i went to
there was maybe two cities i did not
like and i can't even think of what they
are now because as a
i always
part of the reason why i got into comedy
was to see
the united states yeah when i would read
those comic
biographies they would talk they would
always mention when you read the allman
brothers all those books they talk about
these podunk towns
anybody could go to chicago any idiot
could go to new orleans go to lafayette
louisiana
you know go to [__] these are the
places it's funny when you have a
conversation with somebody as a comic
and they don't know you're a comic and
they're like
i'm from
you know st louis and all that you start
spitting out and they're like what the
[__] you and then you they're like how
do you know
how do you know that area and you're
like what high school did you get
because you here now you know people
they start talking about high school and
you're like did you go to lasalle how
did you know you're a brain reader no
i'm not a brain [__] reader i just
i've been here i've been to that you
know
i was telling somebody out there about
misha walker they were like pale
they're like how the [__] do you know
about michelle walker mishawaka is a
part of
indiana it's where indiana and michigan
meet on the bottom
it's on top of notre dame [__]
tremendous little thing and they used to
have the funny bone there yeah i know
the dame it was a [__] thing i booked
you all the time because nobody wanted
to go there and you had to go i went to
go to notre dame for lunch you had to
see the touchdown jesus [__]
tremendous
i got a notre dame football journey the
sweatshirt you know you're over there
that's what you do yeah what's the best
what's the what's the best thing in the
town you go [__] go find the meal
what they're famous for oh you gotta try
this so the food's cool and then you and
then what's well yeah micheal walker
and i'm telling you the only thing in
that town is notre dame i mean around it
it's just kind of now it's different
that was 20 years ago now it's you know
yeah it's a [__] you know what but i
remember going up to east palming
michigan
that's a little [__] yeah that's a
little island
on the u.p the upper peninsula where
[__] it's you know summer is 31
degrees
like that summer you get hit with
snowballs that are
soft you know there's a you know there's
a company called creative entertainment
yeah back in the day but they booked a
whole southeast region of like the
united states and so you could literally
you could do a tuesday night
in uh
you know going over the
uh cedar bluff virginia then you're
driving over to prestonburg kentucky and
down to knoxville for the friday and
saturday and like you felt like a
trucker really like you're putting a
thousand miles but you're you know you
you get to know the rules of the road
real quick it's like you know you just
follow the truckers if you're driving
whatever the truckers are doing you're
doing it you're getting your gas over
there we're getting a gas over there if
the truckers are eating here i'm eating
here i mean you would just go because i
mean literally i would have put a
thousand miles a week i'm like i just
drive into these towns but you get to
see america that's for sure you know
[__] purest form bro philadelphia
mississippi bro there's a place called
philadelphia mississippi ah philly
man like philly bro it was like you know
it was a real kind of and i'm gonna tell
you what he didn't make i'll tell you
what makes that better when you go to
these small american towns and you
actually
have a great [__] time
you have a great time like i went to
i'll never forget this i went to what's
the town
so it's it's seattle
idaho i went to idaho with rico this guy
was six foot six and black
not just black real black and to make it
worse he had a spider tattooed on his
face
like uh he did it with his beard you
know who the guy is yeah up in seattle
good friends of mitch hedberg good
friends with stan hope good just an
all-around guy he told me he was a
criminal from the bronx so one day i got
into a fist fight and i had to hide in a
garbage can so i called him and i told
him to pick me up i'm in the garbage can
by the tornado in the seattle and i
[__] look out the garbage can and
there's rico six foot five a mile away
going like this i'm like rico everybody
could see you even the cops they're
[__] watching they could see you a
big black guy so we take them to [__]
idaho it's a one week run you know yeah
it's not tribble it was donna richards
yeah
this was the eight ball in
tremendous the eight ball in
[__] i go up there with rico the
blackest man in the town
so what is this [__] the next
day i get up you know i bumped into a
[__] grandma coke and
i get up he's calling me we're gonna go
eat breakfast all right we gotta drive
to whatever
we go down to the diner
he's he walks in everybody turns around
it's like he have hot
he's six foot [__] five three hundred
pounds black with a beard a [__]
spider so everybody looks at him what do
you think this [__] decides to
do
he whips out a [__] mat throws it
down he's a muslim he starts praying the
thing you wanted to see why he was
scaring white people to death i may
believe like i didn't know him i just
went to the counter and i just ate when
he came over to sit next to me i'm like
i don't even know you black man sit over
there and everybody's like yeah sit over
there [__] coming in here playing
like a muslim he got down dog in the
[__] restaurant
that's [__] that you can't write that
[__] that i forgot all about that though
this [__] podcast that's hilarious
that's the [__] you can't write the best
ever was i'm on a [__] creative run i
think jimmy pulled for me and ken
phillips yeah you both you guys like
give joey a headliner so i take vinnie
light bulbs with me
and we're in [__] knoxville tennessee
great town college town yeah a [__]
album store second to none i dropped my
whole pay i think they paid 175 to
headline yeah i dropped the whole
[__] check on that [__] neck
in that store i think i got a little
coke we did like clark tennessee we did
like all those bugs
and then we ended up the week in
knoxville
i get on stage there's like 40 people in
the audience i get on stage and i'm
doing my [__] jokes they're not
working it's a bible belt i'm eating a
bag of dicks
but in the audience jimmy schubert is
the hottest woman you've ever seen in
your life i can't take my eyes off this
[__] from the stage i'm going how is
this [__]
in knoxville tennessee blonde
bite-sized titties this is 20 this is
1997.
maybe 98.
i'm doing my stuff and all of a sudden
they want to heckle me
they want to start hacking talking about
sucking dick
and i'm like what's going on over here
and she's like
my husband
when we go home tonight he wants me to
suck the neighbor's dick for 30 and then
they go into a whole spiel about how she
brings it to the job site on fridays he
has a truck and he puts a bed in the
back and everybody [__] up for 30 bucks
this chick was gorgeous she didn't even
know how hot she was nobody ever told
her knowing her and her family he
probably bought her from the father for
like ten dollars in a night for some
[__] jesus like she was gorgeous guys
and she's telling all these stories when
he has ufc fights
and the guys come in the bedroom and
[__] me during the fight for 20 bucks
and i mean this is crazy [__]
so the show ends i [__] you know
whatever thank you for coming i have no
i go to the bathroom i take a piss i'm
going to my hotel room before i go to my
hotel there she is in the hotel lobby
and she's like all those stories i said
were true blah blah blah blah you know i
suck dick i'm like listen you wanna suck
dick let's see what you got
so we go in the bathroom we start swap
and spit and she sucks my dick no big
deal
she goes i had a great time i'll see you
later i gotta go back to my table i go
to my room roll the joint smoke and i go
back downstairs there's maybe nine
people in the [__] audience for the
second show in knoxville
vinnie lightbulb was featuring he goes
up there now i'm looking at her i'm like
what the [__] is she still doing here
god damn it
i thought it was a to go blow job she
[__] lurked over with her husband
and i'm looking at her and she's looking
at me and she's holding on to her eye
because she's hammered
it's like a 22nd birthday the girl is
[__] lit and she's looking over me
now or something vinnie like bubbles go
coming up joey diaz i go up down how are
you guys doing eight minutes nine
minutes into my set
this chick starts crying
and then she goes
i suck the comedian's dick and he came
in my mouth and her husband got up he's
like what and i'm like no she didn't and
it's going oh it's going off in the
showroom
she's like i sucked his dick and he came
in my mouth
and he's like what are you talking about
you suck this dick and i said he's like
i want my forty dollars he's young about
his forty dollars i want my forty hours
did he come in your mouth that's an
extra twenty forty dollars they had to
hold them the cops came
bro he's like i'm no matter what happens
i'm getting my forty dollars now
and i'm like holy [__]
the next night i went down there he
didn't show with us she didn't show and
that was that like those are the things
that you can't write you're not going to
see that on seinfeld
you're not going to see it on larry
david but it's so crazy i know listen
you're not going to see that on there
this is what happens by doing
this is part of the allure like
this is you can't read this [__] in the
book nothing prepares you for this
journey unless you do it this that whole
experience that weekend
probably
somewhere it it helped my career like my
comedy somewhere
because it's that's what it is you're
going out into the [__] highway you
know like julius priest song heading out
to the highway yeah i got nothing to
lose at all it's interesting it's very
interesting yeah but as i go where you
watch like uh when will smith smack
chris rock on the academy awards and
like am i you know my i said that was
probably one of the most unprofessional
[__] things i think i've ever seen
well simultaneously on chris rock's part
being the most professional thing to be
able to hold it together i mean that guy
able to hold it together and then just
like kind of go on and present the show
and i said that's that stand-up training
you've got to do stand-up training like
it's like i mean i'm telling you he was
probably like he was probably like
shocked i was like i just got smacked on
what like what the [__] just happened
but he's
dropped into that stand-up gear and go
okay we're gonna bring the presenters up
and just kind of
do it for i think once you got backstage
you probably freaked out a little bit
like that [__] is really [__]
slightly that's funny that's a good
point i never thought about it from that
perspective because it's true
it's stand-up training a true stand-up
when you're doing 20 years yeah yeah in
the store following people yeah you know
that's that listen if you do 20 years on
a ship
you christopher columbus i mean if you
do [__] 20 years from you know
green bay and all that [__] you you
become really good i mean guys you get
like i remember when i did the episode
of marin
like i hadn't acted in like a month or
two
but it shocked me guys
with the work i was doing on that
shocked me like what what this come from
yeah the 17 weeks i spent on the longest
yard that's a long time to be acting in
a row
yeah yeah in a row you we usually act
one week and then we move on for eight
months then you got one day and then you
move on but 17 weeks that teaches you
[__] that teaches you how to prepare the
camera how to look how to block yeah i
could rock with anybody and my buddy uh
my buddy rob cullen him and his brother
mark holden they wrote uh a bunch of
[__] nominated back in the game they put
me in a bunch of stuff and he says and
he did that joker called lucky with uh
billy gardell and craig and rom but he
said guys i love working with stand-ups
because you guys don't
[__] flinch you know it's like you
know you know there's a lot of these
actors are like man it's just like
everybody you don't even know what
[__] sucks is all right this is
[__] great let's get let's get it on
you know because it's like uh yeah
because you do all those [__] games i
want my 40 dollars yeah you know
now you're acting and you know that's
that's great though i love that i love
doing that i love being able to mix it
up i advise any young comic all these
young comics have these new
[__] brainwave ideas about you know
they're all focused about social media
and i get it guys i get the social media
angle more than anybody i love it too
but i'm gonna tell you something
the most important thing you could do is
to get those first five years and get
yourself into the worst situations you
can
for me like if i
jiu jitsu it would be for me to go
to class every day and have somebody
lay on my [__] chest and me get up
it it either be a black belt choking me
and me get out from that position that's
what doing those triple runs nobody
wants to do triple runs everybody wants
to do the improv everybody wants to do a
theater but nobody wants to do these
one-nighters and guys
that's where your [__] strengths
gonna come from plus it's the greatest
adventure it's the greatest adventure
they're doing stand-up comedy is
probably freaking israel ireland all
over europe munich and through germany
and edelweiss and doing these military
tours in china and asia and south
america and all over america it's a
great giant adventure man if you can get
out there and that's what it's about i
think i think that's the journey of
getting out there and doing it and
living that love you're right you know
everything on social media but it's you
know it's
you got to do that but you also i
watched an interview with a young comic
a couple weeks ago he's going on the
road and doing a tour
and the guy's sitting there like talking
about he's got this new idea for comedy
and there's this new age and i'm like
you know i've been hearing this [__]
for 2 000 [__] years
this [__] and it happens every day
in america
don't lift weights
climb up a wall that's better for you
you know everybody's got the idea what's
better for you but nobody wants to do
the nitty-gritty work
and the nitty-gritty work let me tell
you something i'm [__] proud that i
did that nitty-gritty work because it's
who you are yeah it's who you are it's
not gonna be a perfect [__] night
you're not gonna walk on that there's
gonna be a carpet
dog how many times did you work hard in
your hometown when you first started and
somebody got you with a one-nighter and
you were expecting [__] the playboy
club and you got that it's like where
the blue blues brothers performed yeah
when they got bottles thrown at them
colorado [__] in the old days they
had great colorado had [__]
chicken wire with a little thing with a
comic to walk in and they told you on
the [__] thing if the room is active
if anything should occur run to your
room and call the manager and dial 9-1-1
that was the thing that tribble put in
the bottom of that the room is active
i'll never forget that it was it was
boulder on tuesday craig on thursday
friday was grand junction and saturday
was pueblo that was that [__] run
then he had potato run one and two
oh my god potato run is ever he has two
potato runs
in [__] idaho two of them so once you
finish the one you come back the other
and here's the beauty of it potato run
two and potato run one
have a room across the street from each
other
so when you do potato run one on tuesday
you're on this street when you do potato
run too you're back here how do i know
because i ended up in jail because the
potato run number one some guy heckled
me
and i told him to go [__] his mother and
then when i was doing
potato week number two i bumped into the
guy when i was eating chinese food at
the mall in idaho and him and his friend
came up to me chewing tobacco like you
think you're a tough guy and [__]
and the next thing you know i [__] i
go they go we want to take you outside
and fight you i go listen there's two of
yous you both wanna i gotta fight you
one at a time and they started talking
to me like like really you want to fight
us one time i'm like these guys can't be
they're stupid yeah so the guy turns
around i took the tray of chinese food
remember like uh what's that chinese
panda
panda always throws the [__] noodles
at you there's a little mane [__]
carbohydrate cancer noodles i took the
tray when he turned around i hit him in
the [__] head
it hit him and the noodles stuck to his
head and the noodles are falling off one
by one so i'm running out of them all
and then like come back he hit me with
the noodles and all this [__]
and they arrest me
for [__] i don't even know what they
arrested me for and the guy had to bail
me out they arrested me at six and they
bailed me out at 905 i came out right in
time for the [__] show at the club
that's what happens on those triple runs
potato run i also fingered an indian
chick and she had a yeast infection at
the club because all those potato
all those gigs start off like a comedy
show but then they turn into like a
disco nightmare
it's like
awesome
they start ladies yes and yeah they stop
moving silver ball comes down and drops
you and they want you to host a bikini
contest
you have no idea it but it's all
part of the [__] gig
it really is when they start moving the
chairs out and you're like what
they're like giving you the light you're
going into your best bit you have like
eight minutes and you know the greatest
thing oh my god it was all like the
electric slide like the everybody yeah
and you're in middle america like and
everybody just gets out of the dancing
they're doing with the cowboy and the
cowboy boots but they were all doing
that billboard line dancing they were
coming so
the [__] place turns into a dance you
don't feel too good after that you go
but like if you bomb at the show
and then it turns into a disco night and
you go up to a girl and she's like
weren't you the comedian that bombed the
show you're like
okay you just go right to your room
depressed bro you start crying as you're
writing new jokes you see the tears
hitting the paper and [__] because the
chick told you you suck
nobody really has
an idea like the first road gig i had
had they told me at the [__] lounge
you have to share the room with the guy
you know what that's like all your life
you're reading these books
and yeah let's say you get to your first
gig you're gonna share a [__] room
with a guy with size 14 feet he's
picking his toes the whole night and
[__] you're like god damn it you know
god damn it nobody ever understand this
is why we end up [__] up
because the beating you take early on i
could come with it oh dude the guys come
with it a couple of army cots with some
bubble foam in it i'm i was doing this
my buddy jeff avalon jeff bible used to
do stand up he now this kid used to
stand up with me back in the day he's
from florida i took him on the road with
me right
and we we hooked up with the ron and ron
ron bennington was the ronald rendez
with the disciples of comedy with those
guys
and this dude now this guy produces uh
he's got three shows come on he produced
a show with jamie foxx called shazam
don't forget the lyrics in another show
but this kid
we we got a locked up robe in this
horrible club and there was army cots
with like the bubble foam and i go you
i go that's
i'm not [__] staying here you right
here [__] yours buddy you know these are
the accommodations i got bro i have a
point that i will not [__] cry
i said i said i'm getting a hotel room
he goes yeah good idea let's get a
[__] hotel i'll split it away i said
good let's get the out but i mean like
the cut the beat and you take like two i
think i'm beating guys just a father
thursday friday saturday to like sleep
in a [__] army it's a [__] beast
nobody has a [__] clue of that guy
you gotta tell them the story when you
guys were partying you guys were
snorting coke and you broke the [__]
fire hazard and the next morning you
went to eat breakfast and they put a
[__] hose on your eggs and you guys
got paranoid so you left the hole no no
no no don't happen
but i forgot about that one
i remember all those good road stories
those are good road stories we got we
got a whole bag we got old bags for
worlds and we're we were ready we were
at bennington's club in saint petersburg
talking to the mike guys yeah and so
my buddy uh i'm with my buddy flathead
who's a legendary character you know the
guy he was the boy he was my guy he was
the guy behind the guy so we got all
banged up and uh and so i pulled he's up
on the second floor
and so i see him up there and i grabbed
that fire excuse one of his power once
and so i pulled up
and i'm chasing him all the way down the
outside balcony with this freaking thing
right and all that sweatshirt comes down
on the cars it looks like it [__]
snowed
and i have to watch my footsteps because
i don't want my footsteps leading back
to my door and going to go oh this is
the guy who must have did it so i get so
we get back into the room the next day
we get up and you see all the cars it
looked like it [__] snowed
it's like oh [__] we go to this place
across the street called lenny's and a
great little breakfast joint and i got
the five alarm omelet
it was [__] hilarious
we just [__] started dying but uh yes
you know man it's very it's really weird
when i was writing the book i talked to
erica about this it was really weird
i didn't quit comedy
like i i think about that all the time
because i had some horrible luck for a
while like my first five years i get
momentum then something would happen i
get momentum but i kept coming back like
it wasn't like i didn't do comedy like i
i would keep coming back like i would be
back the next night but it was always
like somebody was banging the wind in my
sails i was never complete in the
beginning because i got like the beating
that you get you cannot you know there's
still dog i [__] look i grew up
loving elvis
you understand me i idle when you're
cuban elvis is a bad [__] elvis
is a bad [__] when you're irish
elvis was a bad [__] revisit his
movies you know when you're a kid and
you're watching elvis yeah you want to
[__] be elvis i forgot what i was
getting to hear
but yeah you're funny i mean you know
dude i remember i was like i was
thinking about it today when i started
like when i was nine-year-old nine years
old i got this freaking
i got a stupid [__] magic kit but
then i that turned into like i was
started doing shows i was like 13 14 i
was doing
like i was getting like five or six gigs
i would go down to
saint christopher's hospital in
philadelphia and you would go i'm gonna
just go do a show for the kids oh that's
great and so i would do it that's how i
would get better and you're doing shows
for the kids and you know and come out
and do that and then all these uh
black nurses that worked there said well
you got to come to our church you're
going to come to our church and so
like i go all right yeah i came over so
i would get these gigs my old man would
have to drive me into some of the worst
neighborhoods in like west philly you
know he's in a beat-up pickup truck i
got this [__] shoebox at the time and
we come in and do magic and these and
that's kind of i mean i've been thinking
about how long i've been performing i
think i got that's like i haven't i mean
i have a lot of jobs to pay the bills in
between but this was always kind of like
the goal i don't know how to do anything
else this is my [__] life and i still
[__] love it yeah you know so it's uh
it's really what i was getting to the
elvis thing was that i liked albus now i
can't look at all this
because i did a [__] nine-month
tenure under elvis
[__] dude
an eldest person
in denver i had to bring him up on
wednesday nights and i kept blasting
like i didn't think about it for years
until i told the story and now i'm like
[__]
i can't believe i tolerated that beating
everyone the guy would give me a small
50. you know tell these people
what a small 50 is on a wednesday night
when you're a starving comic it's like a
two thousand dollar check guys yeah you
know yeah
so he would call me out
and i would go he would feed me the guy
was a great cook yeah weighed about 300
400 pounds glad he was a great cook they
bought him out at one of the casinos he
was an elvis guy for like 20 30 years
yeah and that's what he did he wanted to
open up a little italian restaurant but
he opened it up in commerce city
colorado
behind a bunch of truckers and [__] it
was a cute little plant only had four
had maybe five tables but you know i've
told the story before
till this day i'm like what the [__] was
i thinking
because i would have to go up
do 15 20. he would let me do whatever
that's what what else i did it yeah
because everybody else was giving you
ten eight minutes seven minutes yeah he
will let you do 20. i would die ten of
those minutes
but i would bring him up so he'd come
out first as the waiter
okay and he'd like pour the food
whatever he cooked too so he cooked he
did the book waited on he had a waiter a
waitress that was like his niece and
then he came out how are you doing
that's kind of old
and then he god be right back let me
throw some garlic bread and awesome done
he comes out come out with his elvis
he'd give me like an eyeball like and i
go oh lady a treat elvis is in the
building coming to the stage the great
tony is elvis and he would walk through
the thing and go up there and i remember
have to sit there and at first i liked
it you know
but then after like 20 minutes
you're like how much can i you know it's
10 o'clock at night i got to put up with
this guy moving his body fat going
everywhere you could smell the celery
powder because when you're fat your dry
skin that's celery powder sometimes
you can smell it like
and i used to sit there but you know
what i became a better comic because of
it it taught me patience
it taught me how to laugh at myself you
know
when i lived in seattle was a booker
that didn't like me i called her a
[__] witch one night i didn't like
her either
but she had good rooms and i called her
one they're like listen i know you don't
like me i'm not looking for a booking
can i do guest sets in your room and she
would go you can do whatever the [__]
you want i could can't last so every i
knew she hated me
so every wednesday i'd call her and go
hey i'm going tomorrow night to do
your [__] every every [__] week i
would call her right and one day she's
like you're such a [__] loser for
doing these rooms for free and i'm like
not really
you're the [__] loser you're fat
you're sitting on your ass
and at least i'm doing [__]
better shows that i'd be doing if i was
a regular open mica i'm doing them in
front of david crow and all those
seattle guys and i'm getting better i'm
improving so what you don't pay me what
do you pay anyway 25 bucks
i'll do it for free and be better than
you now [__] come back 10 years from
now and tell you how you sucked as a
book and i'm better than you as a comic
it's a shame she died so i never had the
opportunity to come back and call her a
[__] dead witch
suckers
but it's a real journey
and a lot of i have a lot of guys on the
patreon that are young comics and they
ask questions and stuff and i encourage
them and i encourage them to stay in the
game
you know there's nothing like getting
[__] on and then how about getting [__]
on and bombing
how's that drive home for you yeah and
not getting a dime for it and you were
supposed to be home at 11 but it's 12
[__] 30 and you got to be up at 6 for
work so you just ruined tonight today
you know and now but when you're a comic
you know that there's all it's like
being a street person
tomorrow's another day
somebody kicked my ass today but i'm
gonna go home eat a roast beef sandwich
and i'm coming back
and you better be ready for uncle joey
tomorrow and guess what if you beat me
up again tonight
i'm coming back thursday that's comedy
yeah that's comedy in the beginning and
if that's not what you want to do don't
get involved in it if you think making
funny jokes on twitter is going to get
you go ahead
but you're not yeah it's going to get
you going for a little while you're
gonna sell out big shows you're a big
shot but what happens
when you get an opportunity presented to
you you can't cover the [__] spread
because you never want to do the work
it's like when people want a headline
but nobody wants the mc [__] you you're
not gonna make it because the mc is the
quarterback of the [__] show you dumb
[__] yeah and if you don't know
how to navigate the team how are you
gonna get to the [__] promised land
so think about that yeah i've always
said that i always say you're going to
be great you're going to be great mc
that way you'll be a great feature act
if you're a great feature act then
you'll be a great headliner because you
know there's a show because you know
yeah and so
you know i don't know what you know you
got to do it you just know there's no
shortcuts and that's the one thing i
love about comedy there's no you can
fool some of the people some of the time
you go for all the people some of the
time but you cannot fool all the people
all the time and you can rest assured
and i'm telling you that you'll come up
the first time i work with kennison
we're doing this place called bogarts in
cincinnati and it was this big weekend
freaking thing there was a there's a
firework show which it was tied in with
this radio station it was like a giant
giant event and it was the first time
i'm on the road with with kenneth said
and i go out and man i i blanked i blank
for like 30 seconds and then someone
yelled something i said shut the [__] up
and it got me out of it and i slowly
slowly got the setback and started
getting them by the end of the set i had
them [__] going i had to go and i was
able to yeah i was able to go okay i
kind of pulled it up i pulled out i was
headed for the size of the mountain
pulling up we did the white knuckle pull
up and then i walk off i said that's it
i'm probably not gonna work with sam
anymore because i forget and he goes and
he said to me because not i guess i
would have rather have you seen that set
because now i know you can handle it you
know there's no other guys where i
tanked that set how many guys have a
tank that said you you were able to pull
it up no now i know you can handle it
some guys would have just [__]
continued down but so yeah but
you got to do those things until you get
until you can do those things on stage
like you said you you if you don't do
all those other shows all those little
shows you won't know how to pull it up
and sit and save a set so like it's
interesting i didn't get on stage for
like a year i got on stage a couple
weeks ago with uncle dino from my
mandina
yeah and then thursday night i went uh
with callan on saturday night and it's
funny how
you know the first set just blew up my
head right it just scrambles you the
night i went with tom segura right then
the one when i went with uh dino that
night
i was struggling a little bit yeah i
could feel myself digging
the set i did thursday at the stress
factory
i felt it like okay yeah it's back three
quarters back you know
i'm three quarters back i'm light on
material but i'm three quarters back so
thursday i had a hard time sleeping
because i came home and i had to go back
to the basics i had to watch the my
favorite uh
anything for comedy for back to basics
it's rodney's special when he has
kennison roseanne yeah that is
you know if i ran a comedy camp for a
week yeah and maybe you would say you
show that every night and break it down
break down each set hicks following dice
is a brilliant set
uh sam
following shimmel or somebody yeah
brilliant there's a couple things that
if you watch those sets
you will learn so much out to a degree
and then you have to go out and [__]
uh that's interesting yeah because i
could i talked to sam about that side we
talked about that i said that was oyo's
that was the one thing he kind of it was
one of the things that kind of like put
the pivot to launch it was a planned
series of things that happened to him
after that where he blew up but he said
he said this was one like the one thing
he goes we got there with these guys and
he said i sat there and i went over
every single word of my act with the
director he goes i'm going to do this
i'm going to do this so we're going to
cover he's well we can't we could shoot
you know and when i and i always
remember that piece of advice it's like
he just he sat there i did the same
thing when i shot my comedy central
professional like i went over everything
and that's why i was able to get out
like i looked back at that
i'm gonna figure back in a bit [__] how
[__]
[__] the sideways
[Music]
yeah but the [__] the director just
shot around because i took the time and
put the time and he shot around all the
stuff so i got away with it i couldn't
believe
what they got away with i mean before
they go into that room i said over half
a case of wine i said here's a couple
glass of wine for you guys to do the
just don't touch the airplane bit and
don't touch the [__] congenital twin
bit we're good and boy they did me
[__] right they did it they did a
great job but i mean i but i only
because i heard sam say that goes take
your time when you're getting ready to
film something go over every [__]
note or every little thing so don't know
what's going on and you know you'd be
amazed how many people didn't do it like
the week we're doing those
specials many years ago but i mean you
know guys would just come out you know
on
a [__] skateboard i i was not a good
special shooter
but
i've reviewed my special the last two
years and i saw where i went wrong
and it's really [__] weird how
you know i have to relearn again like
this is the stuff i'm looking at that's
making my dick hard because it's making
me think of that that apartment in
boulder
when i used to go home at night and sit
and look at a notebook and look at judy
carter's [__] book and you know but
to add to what you were saying if
there's comics watching or anybody for
that matter
uh i went to a writing workshop it
wasn't a stand-up writing workshop it
was a writing workshop when i got to l.a
and i took one thing from that workshop
and the guy we were talking he goes
anytime
you review something
before
you present it like we were talking
about pitching yeah pitching shows and
he's like it's so weird how i got on
pictures of people and they've had a
tremendous product but because they
pitched it wrong they didn't sell it
yeah you know
and they weren't prepared and you really
don't want to go in there with like a
sheet you want to be able to they want
to see you yeah yeah [__]
and he goes i did a study for years i
would do percentages on pitches yeah and
he goes people who went over a pitch
like if we went over a pitch
an hour before the meeting yeah the show
had a higher probability of selling
[Music]
so i took it as
before i go on a stage
like when you go on the road you don't
really have to ride on the road unless
you really want to you know you can
write whatever you want but an hour
before
you know i go on stage on a friday or
saturday night i would always wash my
[__] come out dry myself whatever
hit the vapor pen get put my pants on
like a shirt and go over my set yeah
lightly
light lightly i don't want to
know it like a script not because you
want to be able to jump around
yeah i just want to know it and then i
would turn the page over and write like
let's do this set with number two first
number eight second and i would do [__]
like that and it would i tell you man it
helped a lot
it's a big [__] percentage for you to
do better so if
going over your material
before you go on stage that's always
been a plus and i went over it when i
shot the specials but i didn't go over
it the right way and i didn't prepare
the right way yeah there's a way to
prepare see how jimmy and i were talking
about this before we started the podcast
when i met jimmy in 97 hollywood was
completely different than what it was
now they took a comic
they put them on the road 15 months
15 weeks of the year and then the other
10 12 16 because remember when we got to
l.a they were shooting
26 episodes in the season yeah 26
episodes 26 episodes that 213 season
episodes that's 13 weeks if you're
shooting tv they're going to be a break
so probably 16 weeks times two that's 32
weeks so let's say you're on 10 of those
episodes
15 comedy weeks you're working 25 weeks
that's a good [__] living and you'll
sell tickets
comedy shifted
agents weren't pushing comics anymore
for tv shows
tv on the other hand tv started paying
[__] you know money on tv went low
when i got to l.a a guest star was
fifteen to eighteen thousand
now a guest star is seven a [__] ten
you know these streaming services they
don't give you residuals
so it's a one-time payment so
now comics are like wait a second i
gotta do this for three i gotta do a
co-star for 3 500 but i could go to
pennsylvania for eight thousand it's a
no [__] brainerd yeah i i've had to
do a couple negotiations like that yes
it's a no-brainer i was i was i was
gonna wind up canceling four gigs
where i was making like [__]
six grand and this lady had me doing
this like trying to need for these weeks
we're gonna need you for this week we're
gonna need you for that week and i go
well how the [__]
is it that i can make more money on the
road doing standup than you're gonna pay
me for doing this movie i said how is
that even possible i go because i mean
at this point i can just go i don't want
to do i want to do the role i said
work with me a little bit she got the
money up close enough and so i canceled
a couple of gigs and made myself
available was fine but i mean you know
and you would you expect like but also
the negotiation like when you learn when
we talk about not just the work but you
wind up negotiating and booking yourself
on the road and you learn about the
business side of it more than anything
it's like i mean i i swear to god it's
like a lot of these like i'm so
you know i had to do it your whole life
even though you have agents you have
managers a lot of times you're still
managing your manager or agent in your
age or just trying to figure out or
people call you directly you're
negotiating a gig and it's like yeah you
know corporate gig or whatever and so
you know like you said i mean sometimes
you sometimes these people don't even
give you all the information they don't
tell you when you're up for something
because they don't want you to they
don't want you doing it they'd rather
have you on the road because that's how
they make money you know and so it's
it's uh
the business changed a lot but stand up
and stand up yeah stand up will always
be [__] stand up it's four brick
walls a microphone and it's you against
the world [__] and i don't know
that's it and i don't know about you but
especially after the last couple years
i'm telling you people come up on this
on and people forgot
how to [__] laugh oh my god like
they'll come up and just grab me go
thank you so much i needed that like it
was so like it was almost it was like we
were doing a mitzvah for these people
they were like this is like there's the
last two and this last two years has
been tough on everybody like just in in
what you could your life and different
things and family functions and
gatherings and celebrations i mean we're
a social interactive species we need you
know now you put a mask on so you're
just a faceless [__] human and you
can't do this you need to your papers
are not an order no no my papers are
daughter check them again you know but i
mean it's like it's crazy [__] i mean it
was it got it we got it kind of like
this [__] insanity and so people got
everybody just kind of got caught up in
that now people are starting to kind of
get back to normal and and i'm telling
you like i don't know like people came
up and go man thank you so much for
tonight like people
need it more now than ever i think and
so so that also you know turn turns when
it gets me excited to do and i i love
writing on the road i like taking a bit
then i get polished up and start going
on a robot i'm going to drop a new bit
into my into my show what a [__]
great feeling that is to create yeah to
create is
dude so yeah and you're getting a round
of applause with it because now i got
you know 90 of the work i'm doing is on
the paper now you know i've been
performing for so long but i want to go
i mean for me i love coming up with a
hunk of comedy that just and you get
everything you get a round of applause
and the people are [__] dying this is
what i yeah that's what i live for i
love that that's that's my [__] you know
and you're yeah it's but it's uh
yeah it's a high for me too but i
freaking do what are you because you i
know guys get out of standing i don't
want to [__] i don't want to do it
but they just put them up they pull me
back in you know like you just tim allen
tim allen drew carey i mean these guys
don't [__]
i don't need it they just want it they
love it they want to do it people always
go back i mean even like even like the
older guys like bob newhart would go out
and go out and do the thing rickles
reckles never [__] stopped dude
[__] 80. i wanted to take a breather
yeah no i don't know
yeah a lot had happened
you never [__] take a breather yeah
you get all this [__] growing at you one
minute you're [__] starving in an
apartment you're struggling to pay rent
and the next night you're living in a
house in [__] a studio city and how
did you get there like the guy said from
the talking heads how do we [__] get
him i got a wife i got a kid i got a
bike
how did we get here so for me i had an
opportunity yeah to just sit
smell the roses that i never did since i
was 16 and see what i wanted to do
i wasn't done with comedy i just wanted
to see
where these changes were yeah comedy in
the world nobody knew we were dying from
touching the [__] mail three years
ago so nobody [__] knew what was
going on
and i'll tell you these last two years
the same thing long as saying like you
know i've lost nine friends i mean i
love carla bone mitch walters guys i've
known for years guys who were mentors
and i said the same thing it's like i'm
gonna [__] just go i want to just
enjoy my life a little bit look i don't
have to like dude i'm literally i don't
move the door i'm lit everything is half
what it was like it's like house i mean
twenty six hundred for our apartment
it's 13 50 and like freaking in in
in florida like it's everything's just
half so i don't have to kill myself i'm
not on the road like you know four weeks
out of the month just trying to make
ends meet they get a little bit of
breathing i could play slipping around a
golf do some hot yoga drink some green
tea get my chakras on
the pandemic the richest people got
the most desperate
and i couldn't understand that like
these people have money they're
comfortable
why are they acting so desperate even
now today when you look at instagram
look at instagram look at the people who
are acting desperate on instagram and go
why are you doing this
this is just stand up this is fun
you're getting helicopters to shoot
videos for a [__] date what is going
on here
they have blown this out of proportion
yeah and that's why i wanted to keep it
simple i'm not going off like that
anymore i never quit comedy i just
wanted to give it a breather see where
the [__] i was at and see who the [__] i
was at at 59 years old who the [__] am i
one minute i was doing time [__]
kidnapping somebody the next minute i'm
on stage with dice in vegas talking
about gay people at a hotel that we're
gonna build a hotel and every hour on
the hour a big black [__] would come out
and sperm would come out and the gay
people be on the bottom line no no no no
no no no no no no no well two years
before i'm doing time with a bunch of
black dudes and puerto ricans and we're
eating [__] grilled cheese on a
[__] on an iron and all of a sudden
you're in vegas with andrew and then
you're in a movie with adam sandler yeah
you can't process this [__] because when
you go to pri everything's going in your
mind so i just wanted to take it down i
had the opportunity to do it yeah i'm
happy i did it i'm doing this [__] now
on my terms it's to replace
dog it's the [__]
kill six hours a week you know what i
missed
i didn't miss
going to the store anymore i didn't miss
going to a [__] theater you know what
i really missed
i missed going like comedy underground
on monday night
and me coming up to you going shoes i
don't mean to bother you how much money
you got you're like i got 14 tough
i got 15. mike what do you got 10 that's
35. we could get a half gram and we
could split a cheeseburger between three
people and that worked just fine
guys that worked just fine
you understand me nobody was losing
their mind you knew what you had you
knew and you accepted it
somewhere along the lines
comedy got taken out of that context in
my world
i just wanted to go somewhere on mondays
and tuesdays and crack 10 jokes
smoke some joint with the guys maybe
pick up a hit ass and go home
maybe get your dick sucked by a crazy
open mic chick you know
i love that and
it got into something else for me and
now i'm trying to bring it back to that
level in my mind did i i remember like i
was talking to where the comedy store
when damon wayne said come in it was
after he kind of blew up but i've always
loved damon damon was he was one of my
favorite comedians he had a sense of
honesty about a standard he was like he
was like the closest thing i saw richard
pryor like i thought damon wayne's was
[__] hilarious he wasn't and he would
go and he would and he would go once my
juice is gone i'm gone and then like if
you bust the audience's boss and just as
this juice would get down to the end i
would walk a grip with another glass of
juice
oh look what i got i got another glass
of juice and he was gonna bust her balls
but i love watching david but he said to
me so i'm funny when i got mad i said
it's great i said i'm really happy for
your success i mean that show took off
and all this he goes yeah man he goes i
gotta tell you something because the
funnest times i had
was doing the stand up for 25 bucks a
night when you didn't and now people are
throwing three million okay now be funny
and it's like it's like what the you
know i mean you start down horrible
horrible yeah
not not not that it's horrible but i
mean it's like it takes an adjustment
you have to if i can go take a let me go
take a breather but he said it because
the funnest nights i've had here at the
comedy story was those nights just where
you didn't have any pressure you could
just be what you wanted to be and do and
man i was the comedy store for 30
[__] years i mean dude like you said
you you've seen these these different
guys come through and it's like i just
love doing [__] stand-up i don't need
i don't have to be in an arena i don't
want to fly in a [__] leer jet with i
just love making [__] people laugh
man and
you know if you can do that at a high
level like you know what you're saying
so at one point it used to be great to
be a great [__] stand-up it was like
carlin i mean carlo you think carlos was
running around doing [__] podcasts no
the guy put together 21 [__] albums
14 hbo specials he wrote [__] eight
books he was a content [__] monster
if i lived to be 80
you'll never see anybody to put out that
kind of kind of his 21 [__] albums
there's a lot of comedy
and man he's like you know to me i mean
you know that like i i watch carl it's
it's it's amazing you know and
uh but yeah you that used to be great to
be a great comic was good enough and you
but now it's you're right you got to do
you know social media it's it's a lot of
work it's a lot of work this time it's
gonna be a great comment yes i just
wanted to crack jokes hold your
attention you know be interesting
and i wanted like what you said in the
beginning listen
people love when they go to a comedy
show and the waitress drops a tray of
drinks and you [__] with them if you're
funny and on point people want something
they want something to kind of happen
you know what i'm saying they kind of
want something to happen a lady to pass
out that just adds to the show if you
bring your 50 minutes of heat you know
it's a great [__] experience and i
never really
was thinking bro guys like me can't
retire there's no way i can't watch tv
in the daytime
so there's no way i can't retire i feel
like a [__] loser when i put the tv
on the daytime so what are you going to
do you got to go somewhere you got to go
to the gym that puts the tv on in the
daytime you're right yeah no you can't
no i was holding a friend of mine i've
been at ups 40 years we were talking at
the dinner two months ago and then when
are you going to retire he goes i'm
gonna die at that office he goes they
want me to leave in the worst way they
don't want to pay me no more 40 years at
ups he's broken every record he's done
every job they had he drove he broke
cases he supervised and he's like but
i'm not staying home
he was telling me they give him six
weeks a year
and his wife gets two and he takes the
two with his wife but the four that they
give him he works them he goes what am i
gonna do in that house by myself monday
and tuesday because by tuesday you're
losing your [__] mind
so there's certain people that want to
go fishing and [__] like that in my
world you you you
what's the expression carmen balzano
once told me when you stop using it you
lose it oh yeah you lose my body of
motion stays in my body motion stays in
motion you know i was sitting that i
thought i could [__] sit here and go
to school plays and maybe set my coach a
[__] high school basketball that's
not going to happen no one's going to
hire me i got 18 felonies who's gonna
[__] hire me so all i am is a dirty
stand up till i die i'm gonna do it
[__] you know yeah but you know the
good thing is you said earlier you said
i'm doing it on my terms
yeah but that's that's king yeah that's
the king that's you're right that means
that you're never going to hear me go
hey jimmy hi can you do that can you
help me with this i'm doing a special
for netflix and i'm trying to put
together no get the [__] away from me
you'll never hear me say that ever again
hi can you look at this bit because
they're coming from netflix go [__]
yourself you [__] charlemagne
[__]
the [__] is never that that you have no
idea guys you have no idea how great it
is to get off the stage and some [__]
witty [__] agent comes up to you and
says hi i really like your set but i
wish you wouldn't have cursed you know
what the best thing about my set is you
could go [__] yourself with your [__]
[__] [__] glasses you know nothing
about if you had balls you'll be out
stealing for a [__] living but
meanwhile you're [__] pimping out
[__] comics to go around the world
and put them in bad situations while
you're at home eating [__] popcorn
watching the rams [__] the [__] is
wrong with these people
and i used to love that i used to love
you
i it's the love of the guys would go the
managers would come up and go hey
i got a few notes for you go [__]
yourself if you had any notes you beat
somebody but you're too busy pimping out
[__] people here's the greatest
[__] story i'm getting ready to
[__] take my spell i'm producing my
special i got my buddy coming in the
director we got the [__] gear set up
i'm [__] putting the whole thing
together he goes yeah man this man goes
yeah i'll step in i'll do this thing is
you know i go i go yeah well you said
you're going to do that you never did it
you said you're going to do that you
never did it because you're saying you
know we got we got it taken care of all
right i'm going to sit around wait for
you to [__] give me permission to go
do it this was my plan all along i
didn't need you he went in i mean you
didn't get in and so he sits there that
night he comes there and he's [__]
sitting there eating like a [__] the
show sold out we took out a bunch of
front rows there's a line out back you
know shot at flappers but they sell it
up we'd like to set the room the way we
want it
and
dude this [__] guy comes over and she
goes hey listen do you mind if i move
you over to this table she goes we're
using every seat here but you can sit at
this table and finish your meal
and this guy throws a [__] hissy fit
and [__] storms out of the [__]
joint
like this and he was texting going bro
i'm filming i'm feeling much special in
like [__] 15 minutes what the [__]
are you doing
he goes that [__] pissed me off i'm glad
she wasn't a [__] network executive i
waited three days and i sent him a
[__] email i said we're done
i mean but but like like these are the
kind of people you're [__] like
you're gonna [__] that's what i'm
saying like all this [__] [__] all
the stuff i i know how the [__]
producer's fine how to do i didn't need
your [__] help you volunteered you
told me you're gonna finance after
things that was a [__] complete
[__] douchebag but you've run into so
many of those people in [__] shows
and if you don't know what the [__]
you're doing you let these charlatans
lead you around
should i wear a sport coat hey put on a
chicken outfit you'll go up just like
they did the advice you've heard from
these guys these managers like [__]
parasitics would just kind of even at
the low level [__] guys would just
like they could get
manage some of these comics and wait for
them to [__] become famous and then
they would [__]
have to pay you off to get out of the
[__] contract that was their business
plan this guy but i mean it's kind of
like but you're surrounded all those
kind of guys i had like three people
call me as soon as i landed here
to manage it oh
yeah oh
and it was [__] pathetic and i felt
bad for them
and all three of them had no clue what
they were talking about
like i i listen i'll hear you out yeah
i'm the type of guy you're buying lunch
i'll hear you out i always got something
to do it's a quick lunch
it's a quick lunch i gotta go but i'll
give you an opportunity right that's
what you do you give people an
opportunity i sat with like three people
and they were all three of them
were like low-level you know
at the same time i wasn't looking for
[__]
mr saturday night yeah but i'm also
looking for a kid who wants to make his
balance yeah you know some guy that's
like you know what like gitland remember
gitlin yeah he reached out the other day
yeah i always speak to him i talked to
joe i love the time we had the same
manager jeff gatlin yeah [__] guy if
i had him five years ago
it would have been a different ball game
i would have slept that night but he got
out of the [__] business
yeah
i tell him that all the time i mean some
india is where you can back into bro but
get you come out of retirement i asked
him once and he's like who manages you
here and he started calling people i
said you want to go back to work about
three years ago right before the
pandemic yeah and he's like who's over
there you know like uh
did you see the sopranos when the father
was gonna build the house
yeah for the daughter yeah yeah and the
inspector came
and he's like uh get get on the horn
with pudgy welsh and he goes pudgy welsh
retired 15 years ago well get on the
home with jimmy schubert
jimmy schubert hasn't worked there in 30
years well get me
alan alder he retired about 15 years ago
that was jeff gatlin yeah and i was like
jeff here
that's it yeah you can't he was like the
man you know he yelled
i was in the car with him one day he was
going off on a big time she's huge now
he was going off on how about billy
gardel because he believed in his
clients yeah it was me you gardell nick
depaolo i think yeah
johnny sanchez johnny sanchez yeah he
they called him batman's villains yeah
he said
and dawg when this guy believed in you
like i didn't listen
i loved my agents that i was working
with but i really got a little upset
last year and i told jimmy when
they got accused of things and these
so-called agents
[__] run the other way these guys are
up your [__] ass guys wait till you
hit one day and these guys are at your
shows lighting your cigarettes laughing
at all your jokes but also there's an
accusation from some [__] crazy woman
and they'll call you up and go like we
can't manage anymore well [__] you then
then what you know what are we doing
here i mean look at look look at what
look at i mean you look at that you go
these are the people i count on now
these are gonna be a conscious and these
people wrote because you know why
because they're guilty because they knew
what was going on they didn't say
anything and you allowed to go on
instead of [__] pulling your client
aside and [__] you know dude i mean
you know
um
yeah you've seen some stories over the
years of different guys and you know
it's uh i didn't like it anymore and
jeff getlin really fought for us
yeah i liked it he ruined it dude he
ruined it because he did fight for i
mean dude this guy he picks me i flew in
picks me up in his car drives me to the
[__] audition
sits for me waits outside and then
[__] drops me off i mean like and
it's for a part i got the job it was the
rob williams one hour photo thing and it
would only work for like three [__]
days but still it was with robin
williams my scenes were robin williams i
get to [__] you know but i mean dude
pick me up at the [__] airport drove
me the gig waited for me to come out and
drop me i mean like look that's a
[__] real manager i mean you know and
people go what do you want like when
people i don't know what [__]
managers should be able to [__]
organize like you get a [__]
voiceover career you gotta [__] a movie
career you gotta this these guys should
be able to [__] coordinate and
organize all that [__] and also [__]
have you covered you know uh but yeah
it's it's not that way anymore we don't
even we don't remember we picked me up
on a sunday
took me to an audition
i snorted all my pay so he took me to
lunch
he drove me this audition that was no
pay the movie didn't pay but he wanted
the real to get me another movie and he
got me the other movie and i never
forgot him for that and didn't that we
i love jeff gatlin if he told me
something i did it he got me into
auditions
that i wasn't even in the neighborhood
ready for
he got him an audition one time schumer
went out got a little [__] tipsy went
to the audition [__] it up
he got him in the next day because he
said schubert had too much coffee do you
remember oh you know what it was no i i
was i literally got up i work with my
action it was six o'clock in the morning
and i was just i i really like i drank
and like because i don't know if you
know how you know how nerve-wracking is
you're walking in there's 30 people in a
room that's like a one and one bedroom
apartment and they're like on top of you
you just signed a contract that says if
you get picked for this role you're
making thirty three thousand dollars for
the [__] thing you should start
you start getting the you know you still
get the [__] start thinking about cause
you start to want it and the minute you
do that you're [__] but you make it
too important you can't give anybody
your power what i say is you can't give
them your [__] power look i'm gonna
make my choice i'm gonna go in and i
work with this woman named karen west
who was like the vince lombardi of
[__] audition skills [__] car
she's amazing she's still in la she
works all the time every time i turn to
tv i see her she played
she worked with robert de niro she's a
[__] you know one of those iv
uh yale drama school i mean just anyway
she's a great uh
was a great coach but i started booking
everything with this lady like she's
just you know you get a hold of a you're
gonna
but he did i got on this one i got too
nervous and i was like i it just
snowballed i remember you before me let
me tell you how good jeff is i [__]
this audition up and he got me in there
to read the next day and that's
i'm telling you man we were spoiled with
that [__] and then when i went
on with other people they were just
terrible before we go
what do you think
about chappelle getting tackled last
week because a bunch of people ask me i
don't even know how to [__] address
it so i'll give it to you well i i get
well they they really well first of all
that dude got [__] up they broke his
arm i mean jamie foxx was there jamie
foxx yeah he came running out of there
before anybody and stomped on the dude
and then the rest of the guys came
running out but i mean it's dave
chappelle man dave's got a a crew and a
posse that love him and yeah the guy
uh like i
it was about time like like the other
thing is like that it's the different
difference between the will smith thing
and that it's that's completely
different i think you know that guy but
just you know the security will be
beefed up and even guys like i talked
with dino some of these other bigger
name acts that are coming you have to
hire a bouncer if they come down to work
the weekend now but you're setting a bad
present and if you just can't handle it
stay out of the [__] comedy clubs
really i mean you
look it's it's you know i gotta try i
gotta tell you i i'd feel bad for
anybody would do that at my show i
certainly wouldn't [__] chris rocket
he'd probably get kicked he'd probably
get hit in the shin at the bottom of
that mic stand and then i would just i
just you know i'm not gonna give you a
chance to come up and slap me
if you if you breached if you preach if
you preach if you breach that fourth
wall bro i'm gonna i'm just gonna i'm
gonna assume now that i see what i've
seen i'm gonna assume you're gonna do
something i'm just
yeah i'm not gonna
if it happens i hope i hope it does i
hope it doesn't set a bad precedent but
it's uh
a lot of crazy people out there guys a
lot of people looking
you know [__] worlds yeah yeah you
saw that guy he's mentally ill i mean
bro who brings a gun with a knife in it
with no bullets no no
no no bullets what was that i mean that
was like
that was like the stupidest thing i
think you know the hollywood bowl is a
dangerous place because it's wide open
yeah a lot of people don't know that you
can just go up there in the daytime put
a gun on the way you're gonna sit
it's wide open yeah it's a park
you could just put a gun under your seat
that's what i was thinking about i know
that
you know it's a big stage how did that
guy run across to him you know what when
you're a comedian you're focused and
you're laser beam you don't really see
that hey did you see that dave
chappelle's a big guy he's a big dude
yeah he's a big dude he's just uh we'll
listen whether he's a big dude a small
dude
i just wanted to know what you were
thinking about you think it will happen
again in the future i hope it's not in
the comics
you know attract that certain comics
don't attract it i got a knife sent to
me
i'll [__] put on an anti-splinter
suit you know
well it's it's all i don't even worry
about that [__] you go up there you tell
your jokes you believe in what you
believe in
and there's always going to be some
[__] crazy [__] wants to
challenge you what are you going to do
that's not the goal man my goal is to
make people laugh and have a good time
and if you can't if you can't handle
that then maybe you shouldn't come but i
i think he's people are doing it you
know making everything political that's
a it's a state it's not really they're
just jokes if you can't laugh you don't
have a good sense yeah i feel bad for
these people because like they did you
know being able to laugh at yourself or
having a good sense of humor don't
it kind of takes a mental wellness
because you're able to not take things
so seriously you know and some of these
people just like you people just get so
triggered so easily what the [__] are
you doing is that a lot to be triggered
about the last two years weighed deep on
people yeah it has between black lives
matter the pandemic losing jobs mandates
a war nobody knows whether they're
coming or going you know i just got it
together a few months ago but it's a
it's a [__] cruel world out there
yeah joe
i call it surviving the trauma of human
existence like just trying to put
[__] food on your table make enough
money to pay your [__] bills i mean
you know and you don't and you get and
you get the tools you get and if you
don't have them you should develop them
because it's a you know it's my you know
you know it's a it's a it's a
[__] bro just and live a life
you want man feed your soul fill your
head with beauty and enjoy your life man
that's it
take care yourselves [__] i want
to thank jimmy schubert thank you joey
for making it happen on a beautiful
[__] monday morning here in the
voodoo lounge
in new jersey where are you at next week
cox sucker i'm going out to vegas i'm
doing i'm doing the la comedy club at
the stratosphere working my buddy out of
boston johnny peasy i'll do some shows
out there and then i'm going to head
back i get the rest of the month off i'm
going to relax i'm going to do some if i
get to go do some yoga get back on my
trainer start doing cardio hit the beach
man play some golf enjoy my life i'm
just uh you know like you said i'm doing
it my own i'm doing it at my own pace
now my own [__] pace it's all over
guys i love you [__]
thank you happy monday and i'll see you
[__] wednesday morning
tip top magoo
now for a word from our sponsors jack
all right you bad [__] i want
to thank jimmy schubert for coming over
the [__] house getting a slice of
pizza
i want to thank you guys for always
having my back but most importantly i
want to thank my two new sponsors
bespoke post
listen shake up your daily routine with
bespoke posts and their new box of
awesome collections i think this is
great because you order and they send
you something different every month when
you open it like a little kid at
christmas you know what was in my box
this month i got a tremendous whiskey
glass with a sifter to put the whiskey
in plus a one-hit and a tremendous
little bag plus
they sent me a [__] crocodile dundee
knife it's even bigger than crocodiles
indeed bespoke post partners with small
businesses to bring you the most unique
goods every month
they have collections for every part of
your life like their scorch box with hot
sauces from all over the country to get
started take the quiz at box of
awesome.com and they'll help you pick
the right box for you each box is valued
at around 70 but you only pay a fraction
of that plus
90 percent of everything in the boxes
comes from a small up-and-coming brand
it's free to sign up get 20 off your
first monthly box when you sign up at
boxerawesome.com and enter code joey at
checkout that's box of dot com
code joey for 20 off
your first box box of awesome.com
code joey listen to me i want to welcome
sheath underwear
to the company i've had them for like
two years they're tremendous
if you listen to the joint you probably
got a big dick and you're probably sick
of reaching down getting unstuck from
your [__] balls or your leg thank god
there's sheath underwear oh my god
these underwear comfortable they fit
tight
they're nice plus they keep your balls
off your leg the idea for sheep came
from its founder us army soldier robert
patton it worked for him and he's
[__] over there stabbing people it'll
work for you you understand me that's
how big his balls was he come with a
little pouch in the front too just in
case you're a part-time smuggler let's
not go further than that but anyway go
to sheet underwear dot com use promo
code joey and get 20 off your first oil
that's right 20 [__] percent
off every order comes with sheets
underwear 100
money back guarantee that sheath
underwear dot com
use promo code joey get sheath underwear
and let them support your [__] huge
nuts i want to thank sheath underwear i
want to thank annette
and i want to thank
bespoke post for coming on to the show
this week i love you guys with all my
heart i hope you enjoy the show today
have a great week
stay black and we'll see you [__]
wednesday morning
tip top magoo with another fun-filled
episode of the joint
so
you